bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
adrien de la société time scop qui nous
permet de voyager dans le passé grâce à
la réalité virtuelle alors tu peux nous
expliquer un petit peu là ce qui t'as
une scop ce qu'on peut faire avec
et puis comment voyage dans le présent
le passé
bon rien tu as très bien expliqué au
times top c'est une machine à voyager
dans le temps
concrètement c'est une banque qui est
équipé d'une technologie de réalité
virtuelle qui est dédié aux espaces
fréquentés par le public
que ce soient des lieux qui sont chargés
d'histoire ou alors des lieux qui vont
beaucoup évoluer et dans ces espaces là
on va amener les gens à voyager dans le
temps à travers des expériences de
réalité la seule leçon sur mesure
contextualiser d'accord par exemple
typiquement sur rallye historique
refaire vivre l'histoire du mieux et
montrer aux gens quoi ça ressemblait et
les faire voir à travers les yeux de
quelqu'un par exemple
siècle
exactement depuis le coin sur lequel il
se situe ce qu'ils auraient vu quelques
siècles en arrière
m'hamed times comme ça fait vraiment
penser géo au point de vue quand on
regarde les points de vue dans ces
espèces de
duel mais bien sûr j'ai vraiment
l'impression que c'est sam effectivement
sauf que là on va regarder au loin ce
qu'on va voir on regarde au loin mais
d'en passer c'est exactement ça le
concept devrait dire que on s'est
inspiré la jumelle télescopique pour
retrouve sur des lieux historiques
touristiques ont marre tour eiffel etc
sauf qu'on a mis de la technologie
beaucoup plus évoluée dedans et comme tu
l'as dit ben ça nous permet de nous
projeter
c'est la même principe de projection que
je projetais géographiquement on
c'est à dire de zoomer géographiquement
on se téléporte cette fois ci dans le
temps mais on peut aussi se téléporter
dans l'espace et à dire que dans des
lieux comme des offices de tourisme 0
pas on reste élégante et dans des
destinations en 360
d'accord c'est ce qu'ont fait par
exemple la voici au port de lyon
on a des expériences les clubs sont
disponibles
mais de se téléporter à
on prend l'exemple d'aéroports de lyon
dans des destinations de l'aéroport de
la zone d'embarquement
ça veut dire que par exemple je suis à
l'aéroport de lyon qui arrive joliment
bas où est ce que je veux partir
pas grave le tableau d'affichage bon
allez je condamne ce que je regarde et
en fonction de ce que je vois ce qui
plaît ding ogier exactement c'est
exactement ça alors tu me dis donc on
peut voyager dans le passé
effectivement en étendard regardons
comment et effet le lieu à l'époque on
peut voyager de destinations lointaines
dans le présent puis sur un autre espace
et on peut voyager dans le futur
exactement c'est le troisième cas d'
usage c'est sur des chantiers qui sont
amenés à fortement évolué avec un grand
projet urbain par exemple typiquement
des projets pour le grand paris et bien
sûr les gars du grand paris on va être
amené à se téléporter dans le futur de
ces gars qui permet
le public entre les habitants
l'occurrence et les visiteurs de ces
gars ne se rencontrent d'appréhender les
évolutions architecturales qui vont
vraiment un outil de médiation qui
permet différents types d'expériences en
fonction des lieux et qui m'avait
d'augmenter l'expérience de visite il
ce qui est dingue c'est que je
connaissais pas du tout line up jamais
pensé l'avait ennemi intéresse mais un
peu comme tout le monde comme tu disais
tout à l'heure d'aujourd'hui du gaming
sont des choses comme ça mais maintenant
je vois la bande ça me paraît tellement
évident pourquoi personne n'y ait pensé
à avancer c'est en fait j'ai des
réflexes universel de se téléporter de
réfléchir de renom pas de télé par tv2
de réfléchir à quoi ressemblait un lieu
soit un lieu touristique on va voir
parfois ou même avec vous même un lieu
du quotidien car à quoi ça ressemble et
y accueille à calais on voit qu on
vraiment à ce réflexe au lac est
complètement universel j'ai
effectivement tout voilà board
on comprend tout de suite
bien sûr oui c'est ça alors elle vient
d'où l'idée par l'idée en fait elle
vient de
on associe qui est aussi un
très proche et
très lointain
j'ai beaucoup voyagé notamment dans des
lieux
c'est en voyageant ces lieux notamment à
pompéi qui se dit mais manque un ce qui
manque quelque chose à l'expérience est
une expérience qui est intéressante et
bien sûr mais les travaux de
réaménagement il ya
partout c'est difficile des perches
selphy comment vraiment ce
sera-ce figuré parce que c'était avant
concrètement c'est une technologie qui
apporte un sentiment de présence de très
fort
[ __ ] grand large ou autres à
l'intérieur de ce qu'on visualise donc
nous on a décidé de développer un outil
qui met à discuter les mois
c'est la disposition des vieux et leur
permettre de faire ça à leurs visiteurs
d'accord l'antenne coiffé existe depuis
combien de temps ce site a été créé en
juillet 2015 au caire pour participer à
un concours des grands coups
d'innovations
il en était finaliste dans un beau
couple encourager on s'est dit ok on
touche quelque chose de
fort on a mis en place la première bande
en 2016 place de la bastille qui ont
installé une quinzaine cette année en
2017 et on installera beaucoup plus
l'année prochaine
génial bon bah écoute boue rouge peut
être mais recèle continuation donc vos
clients se sont vraiment c'est le 'b to
b' les offices de tourisme bit c'est à
la fois des villes voilà
d'intercommunalité des départements des
régions
mais ça peut être aussi un secteur privé
comme kerry ou les galeries lafayette
c'est des lieux qui accueillent du
public
ok oui aller chercher un pigeon m'écoute
génial merci beaucoup merci aurais je
vous invite à laisser des commentaires à
me dire ce que vous en pensez est-ce que
vous avez déjà rencontré les bornes
gamescom est ce que vous les avez essayé
si oui dites moi ce que vous en avez
pensé
et sinon est ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser mark et moi tout ça je vous
invite comme d'habitude bien sûr à lui
cédé jolie pousse à vous abonner
parce qu'on va parler toujours plus
d'entreprises françaises innovantes
merci adrien merci aurélien à bientôt
à bientôt